l a tutti ragazzi e poi venuti questo
nuovi dio sono fa vj oggi siamo in un
nuovo blog
ma prima di cominciare spot per noi ehi
tu sei proprio tu vai accesso e scopri
che la carta igienica è finita solo dopo
che hai finito di canale metti la parola
fa vj nel titolo dei tuoi video perché
se no non ti caga nessuno tenti di
rimorchiare ragazze ma non ti si cagano
di striscio e allora il nuovo profumo
acqua di favi è quello che fa per te il
solo struzzo e la tua vita cambierà
totalmente mai più carta igienica finita
al cesso pulisciti culo come cristo
comanda fi trillioni di virus senza
dover fare il parassita di turno e con
che attributi le ragazze cadranno i tuoi
piedi come niente acqua di fare solo
delle migliori l'atr in effetti
dell'italia attenzione a quali può
contenere placidi merda può causare
monito a sfizio e sono le istantanee
mantenere la portata in amico avere
effetti disidratanti grande caldo questo
per merito a chi è bello che siamo
partiti allora prima di cominciare
ragazzi cosa i tori e partire con la
fama della settimana questa settimana è
stata vinta da rebecca che ha fatto sto
disegno bellissimo teatro io ho sempre
desiderato essere in gatto se le news di
oggi ragazzi vorrei dirla alla fine
perché sono un pochettino importanti
quindi li vedi passare direttamente agli
eventi della settimana altro parentesi
il video su facebook quello come pensi
di cantare come canti davvero andato una
bomba quindi grazie anche di quello per
chi non l'avesse visto è questo qua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
le news di oggi ragazzi vorrei dirla
alla fine perché sono un pochettino
importanti quindi per adesso direi di
passare agli eventi della settimana poi
passiamo alle news la prima domanda
arriva da laura baggi che mi chiede fa
vi risponde favi ci fai vedere come ti
prepari quando lavori non è che mi
preparo chissà quanto ora io mi sveglio
la mattina e che cazzo devo farti devo
fare un video mentre vado a lavoro io
sono abbastanza tranquillo oggi non c'è
niente di strano si è alzato ha fatto
per azione
adesso vado a lavoro eccomi sono
arrivato
[Musica]
ok ragazzi perfetto finita un'altra
giornata di lavoro della pesante ma c'è
loro hanno bisogno proprio il mio fisico
prestante e niente adesso vado a casa
così domani mi alzo bello carico e tornò
a mostrare i bicipiti big falle amico
vai un po in palestra se lo dici tu
ok eccoci qua ragazzo aspetta un attimo
lei perfetto ci mancherai sono andato
tante di quelle volte in palestra così
che non avete idea favi ti sei reso
conto che ti stanno crescendo i baffi
[Musica]
original marika famigli sponde fi wi fi
l'add on the job cicinho madonna e
facciamola sta cazzo di challenge che vi
devo dire
leggo
ma che cazzo sei anche a razzo lorenzo
carrozzo la tua vecchi più insetti dei
poveri cristi che hanno affrontato le
cavallette durante le piaghe d'egitto ha
tratto vi ricordate l'insetto con le
norme che c'erano lo scorso slog che gli
ho fatto vedere che bello che sei tesoro
ecco quelli se tu li che ho messo nella
scatola tipo un paio di settimane fa
come l'avrà tolto l'insetto apparterra
la verità diciamo che questa è come l'ho
tolto ragazzi quel cazzo di insetto beh
semplice non l'ho tolto che cazzo ci
devo fare mi fanno cagare
oddio oh mio dio io mi trasferisco in
giamaica quindi ragazzi le domande di
oggi finiscono qua è questo per aprire
il discorso allora questo blog più o
meno ragazzi uscirà il 22 non lo so non
so quanti iscritti saremo il 22 perché
lo sto registrando molto prima questo
blog ma quando uscirà questo video
ragazzi saremo molto ma molto vicini al
traguardo dei 2 milioni di iscritti sul
canale c'è una questione di giorni
quindi quando l'anno scorso siamo
arrivati ad un milione di iscritti
ragazzi
diciamo che dopo quel traguardo io non
ne ho più visti nel senso che a parte il
fatto che non pensavo di arrivare a due
milioni parte anche da questo
presupposto ogni veramente non ho più
fatto neanche tanti speciali perché
veramente vedere il numero 1.000.000
scritto sul canale qualcosa di non me lo
possono anche spiegare ragazzi non credo
si possa spiegare questa cosa è assurdo
non pensavo di arrivare a due milioni
perché pensavo ci fossero così tante
persone in italia che guardassero
youtube quindi quindi oggi a distanza di
un anno più o meno mi ritrovo più a fare
questo discorso è dirvi grazie per ogni
cosa alla fine da quando ho iniziato a
fare video su youtube quindi vi parlo di
dell'estate del 2011 più o meno un sacco
di persone hanno iniziato poi a
scrivermi grazie favi perché mi fai
sorridere io faccio del mio meglio per
farvi sorridere questa cosa qui è il mio
più grande traguardo ragazzi non è la
scritta 2 milioni non è la scritta un
milione non era scritta 200 milioni di
traguardo e ricevere un messaggio che mi
nel quale mi si dice favi tu mi fai
sorridere grazie
questo è un vero cazzo di traguardo non
2 milioni però siccome ci tenete che io
faccia uno speciale perché sono mi
ammazzate di commenti parivar ospitare
il 2 miliardi
lo farò quindi non preoccupatevi però io
vi ringrazio per il suo traguardo ma vi
ringrazio di sorridere you tube da anni
la mia passione ed è diventata negli
ultimi due anni un lavoro ogni tanto
dicevo anche commenti del tipo fabi ma
perchè non rispondi mai ai commenti di
chi ti scruta scrive ste cose perché
oltre a 2 milioni di fan ci sono anche
non 2 milioni ma tipo che ne so
centomila hayter mettiamola così questo
traguardo enorme che abbiamo raggiunto è
stato raggiunto anche grazie a loro
perché loro mi fanno una pubblicità
pazzesca voi non avete idea se non fosse
stato anche per quei piccoli haters che
sono magari i bambini perché la maggior
99 per cento sono bambini avrei molto ma
molto meno di 2 milioni di iscritti
quindi ragazzi invece che rispondere a
questa gente ogni tanto vedo che molti
di voi tentano di difendermi quando io
cioè a me non me ne frega veramente un
cazzo non ho bisogno di essere difeso
non mi sento insultato per niente da
certi commenti ma secondo voi io
smetterei mai di fare video perché un
minchione vien a scrivere sta roba più
di tanto quando sono giù di morale mi
guardo arrivato proprio a cercare perché
mi vien da ridere a leggere certe cose
quindi non preoccupatevi che puoi
scendere anche gesù dal cielo ma io
continuerò a far video anche tra 25 anni
state tranquilli per questo anche perché
il mio lavoro certo e ci tengo a
chiarire come ogni traguardo che
raggiungo che questo è soltanto ed
esclusivamente l'inizio quindi detto
questo ragazzi scrive vi chiederete
tutti fare ma quand'è che fai lo
speciale non ci sarà un solo speciale ma
ci saranno ben tre speciali per il
traguardo dei 2 milioni di iscritti
tenetevi pronti perché saranno veramente
una cosa devastante ragazze altri 2
milioni rega iniziano a fare un sacco di
speciali perché mi ero fermato con gli
speciali non ne stavo facendo più anche
se non ci saranno veri e propri
traguardi iniziano a far speciali così a
casa
quando mi capita quindi preparatevi
perché non usciranno un sacco oltre
questi tre da adesso in avanti quindi
ragazzi ho fatto sto mega discorsone
trita palle che spero sia piaciuto a
tutti quanti
quando l'avete scappato tutti e prima di
concludere dire di passare al affari
domanda che da fare domanda di oggi ex
come me l'avete chiesto tutti
nell'ultimo mese diciamo cosa cazzo è
questa cosa che ciò sul braccio di
farcela fa in amanda e chi azzecca vince
il premio perché devo parlarne prima o
poi perché se non sembra che io mi sia
pitturato da solo cosa significa in
realtà questo tatuaggio qua guardate
oltre quello che sembra perché non è
così semplice
questo è l'indizio ragazzi vivido solo
questo quello che risponde che soltanto
l di death note
ovviamente lo ammazzo è partito il
mistero ragazzi mica testo video i
vostri amici fate vedere sto pezzo del
vive il primo che raggiunge il
significato che è difficile ma non così
tanto riceverà le mie congratulazioni
nel prossimo blog confrontatelo bene con
quello di death note c'è un qualche cosa
che cambia cioè quella la chiave del
significato vero del tatuaggio la smetto
così è mera la smettete di farmi domande
su questa cosa perché non si capisce che
cazzo quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto
sono curioso di menzione che cazzo
scrivete e cosa in ragazzi servito è
piaciuto affatto commento mi piace anche
la pace di facebook economy video tratte
nella descrizione questa anche la l di
like quindi like al video come me ne
approfitto senza presidi scrittrici vi
davano prossimo video della ragazza